bonsoir nous sommes le 12 décembre il
est 18h nouvelle édition en direct pour
le 78 lactu le journal de la rédaction
de TV fil et nous parlerons ce soir de
la réorganisation de ADS entre
suppression de post et également
redéploiement des différents salariés
sur les sites franciliens des Mureaux d
LC nous parlerons de ce nouveau Drive
pour produits laitiers du côté de la
ferme de grigon à plaisir et puis il
sera aussi question de cette
mobilisation intersyndicale pour
dénoncer la situation économique
difficile de l'université ivelinoise on
débute avec cette image du jour la grève
dans les transports en commun à la SNCF
le trafic est perturbé depuis mercredi
soir pour les usagers en gare de
Saint-Quentin suite à un mouvement de
grève de la SNCF la circulation est
ralentie jusqu'à vendredi matin 8h un
train sur de pour la ligne N le RER et
les TER et tr trains sur 5 pour la ligne
u les cheminau protestent contre la
réforme ferroviaire présentée en octobre
par la Ministre chargée des transports
Frédéric cuviler une réforme qui
ouvrirait le rail français public à la
concurrence du privé quelques réactions
d'usager ce matin en gare de canttin en
Yveline B disons que le train que je
voulais prendre ben il y en avait pas
donc j'ai dû prendre le suivant et comme
c'est toute les demi-heur ben je vais
être à la Bour les grèves c'est toujours
pareil donc on arrive en retard on seit
engueuler et puis puis voilà quoi oui
j'ai été retardé voilà j'ai pris une
demi-heure par rapport à mon trajet
habituel on peut être solidaire ouais
avec les gens qui font la grève tout à
fait ouais j'imagine s'ils le font ils
ont des raisons j'ai attendu 20 minutes
sur le qu dans le froid il fait très
froid j'étais gelé c'est embêtant
surtout quand il fait très froid et dans
le cadre de cette réforme qui fait
craindre au syndicat le pire nous avons
voulu savoir si cette idée en tout cas
de privatiser la SNCF recevait un bon
écho auprès de la population faut-il en
tout cas ouvrir le rail à la conc
concurrence pour les transports des
voyageurs vos réponses au micro de
Patrick Jacques de dixmud bah sil peut
faire un meilleur service que les SNCF
pourquoi pas ce sera intéressant puisque
ça ça permettrait de baisser les coupts
non s'il y a plus de concurrence
forcément ce sera intéressant pour nous
quoi peut-être pas pour eux mais pour
nous ouais je pense non ben non je pense
que la SNCF est déjà bien installé donc
pourquoi ramener de la concurrence je je
pense que c'est c'est la SNCF de
s'occuper exclusivement totalement des
des lignes des ras quoi non c'est fou
are rien alors là je vous dis
franchement ça me non je su pas d'avis
particulier d'accord ben c'est difficile
de répondre comme ça rapidement oui ou
non moi je pense que jusqu'à présent la
SNCF a fait quand même pas mal de choses
pour le déplacement des Français donc
démanteler tout ça pour mettre
soi-disant en place une concurrence qui
se va pas aller du tout dans le sens de
favoriser les clients de la SNCF mais
plutôt dégager des marges
supplémentaires pour ceux qui tirent les
ficelles en haut moi je suis pas trop
pour ce genre de de réforme qui prend
pas en compte aussi le le bien-être
aussi bien des clients que des des
salariés de l'entreprise EADS veut
augmenter les dividendes versées aux
actionnaires une information rendu
public aujourd'hui jeudi alors qu'en
début de semaine le groupe
d'aéronautique et de défense annoncé la
suppression de 5800 postes de quoi faire
grimper le titre au CAC 40 il ne devrait
pas y avoir de licenciement sec selon le
PDG de l'entreprise seulement despl de
départ volontaire près d'un millier en
France et surtout une réorganisation des
services les sites francilien des
Mureaux et des lencours sont appelés à
devenir lesépôle défense et espace du
groupe réaction syndicale à cette
situation au micro de cler Cambier c'est
ça notre grand problème parce que pour
cassilien par exemple quand on annonce
360 cassilien en France c'est environ
2500 personnes mais dans allez une
dizaine de structures juridiques
différentes donc aujourd'hui moi je suis
représentant cassidien SAS je sais pas
si est 360 chez cassidan SAS ou si c'est
dans nos filiales aussi donc aujourd'hui
on a aucun détail sur ça on a eu un
chiffre brut 360 points qu'on regroupe
des gens ici ça peut être coûter moins
cher en structure nous déjà on s'est
installé à encour avant on était h sites
en région Île-de-France donc on a
regroupé ici pour que ça coûte moins
cher bon visiblement ça coûte toujours
aussi cher et donc on veut encore
regrouper d'autres gens oui c'est vrai
que louer des
à Suren c'est peut-être plus cher
qu'àencour ou au Mureau d'un autre côté
on veut faire déménager de gens de la
panlieu nord de Paris jusqu'à hencour et
là en terme de transport pour les gens
ça va pas être très simple le réseau
plateau de sa-quentin en iveline à 2 ans
un réseau lancé par la Chambre de
commerce pour mettre en relation des
grands groupes qui deviennent des
coacheurs et des PME qui sont ell coaché
2 ans après l'heure est donc au Bilon
Catherine zulato et LOD moine
jean-fançois Bertin en pleine discussion
il dirige cabinet architecte avec H8
salariés ceux avec qui il échange sont
comme lui chef d'entreprise leur
particularité avoir intégré pendant 2
ans le réseau plateau ou comment un
salarié de grand groupe a coaché des
dirigeants de PME et de TPE et au bout
des 2 ans c'est une réussite 70 PME du
territoire de Saint-Quentin et des
communes avoisinantes et 12 grandes
entreprises ont participé au réseau nous
avons réalisé une étude d'impact à la
fin de ces 2 ans de programme et 88 %
des membres sont satisfaits très
satisfait du programme et 96 % estiment
avoir renforcé leurs compétences
managériales donc je pense qu'on peut
dire que le bilan est positif la
réussite c'est d'abord une méthode
mailler grandes entreprises et PME
autour de thèmees qui interpellent les
ressources humaines le développement
commercial ou encore la gestion des
finances à nous de trouver des solutions
avec la CCI al soit c'est des c'est de
l'animation de réunion soit c'est soit
c'est des intervenants qui sont
spécialisés dans dans le sujet qu'on va
adresser soit soit c'est un panachage
des deux soit c'est de la mise en
situation avec du c-éveloppement c'est
plein de choses comme ça plein d'outils
quand ils sont en groupe comme ça ils
ont énormément de demande donc derrière
si on on arrive en tant que cadre coach
à à faire sortir la demande et puis
faire sortir la pratique associé ben je
dirais on a tout gagné Jean-François
Bertin reconnaît avoir beaucoup gagné à
ces échanges il venait pour rompre
dit-il la solitude du chef d'entreprise
il a trouvé conseil et réconfort les
coach des groupes arrivent avec une
méthode un raisonnement un un savoir qui
leur est certainement transmis par leur
staff et leur encadrement voilà ça on le
on l'intègre on le digère on essayie de
le reporter à notre entreprise j'ai
trouvé plus que mon bonheur d'abord j'ai
trouvé beaucoup de réponsse et beaucoup
de de de cheminement et puis j'ai trouvé
plein de copains parce qu'en fait le
groupe se soude la l'alchimie a bien
pris entre les différents chefs
d'entreprise et voilà j'ai trouvé des
gens qui avaient les mêmes
problématiques que moi et puis a le côté
le côté le gros apporte et le petit
apporte au gros et le gros apporte au
petit et ça c'est c'est très intéressant
quoi c'est très enrichissant d'un point
de vue personnel c'est voilà cette
découverte ça donne même envie
d'entreprendre à plus petite échelle un
vrai coup de cœur décidément après 2 ans
le réseau plateau de 50 an ieline va
s'agrandir au-delà du département à Laam
2014 il accueillera aussi les entreprise
du territoire de Paris sacly économie
toujours la ferme de grigon a lancé son
premier drive laitier c'est le premier
de France les livraisons ont lieu chaque
vendredi le but aller à la rencontre des
clients nous sommes allés voir comment
cela
fonctionnait Antoine fait partie des
premiers clients de ce drive laitier
vendredi dernier il venait chercher ses
produits laitiers sur ce bord de route
après avoir passé commande sur le site
internet de la ferme de grgnon cette
ferme expérimental tente ici une
initiative originale apporter des
produits frais directement à leurs
clients ce camion frigorifique s'est
installé au croisement des routes
départementales en contrebas de la ferme
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait plus
de 26000 voitures qui passaient devant
la ferme et qui s'arrêtaient pas
forcément à notre boutique on s'est
rendu compte que souvent les gens sont
sur des trajets de domicile travail ils
rentrent chez eux ils ont pas forcément
le temps de venir dans la ferme de
s'arrêter d'aller voir la boutique de
faire la queue et souvent il y a des
enfants dans la voiture sortir les
enfants ça prend du temps voilà donc on
a voulu faire un service au offir un
service à ces gens-là pour que ce soit
plus rapide pour cette première en
France une vingtaine de personnes a
passé commande les produits phar yaourt
et faisell les livraisons s'effectuent
pour le moment tous les vendredis de 16h
à 20h si le concept fonctionne les
points de livraison pourrait se
multiplier et l'offre s'élargir des
bières artisanales au caisset
d'agneau on passe à l'entretien de cette
édition je reçois donc deux invités
Jérôme d'vioot bonsoir vous êtes maître
de conférence à l'Université de versaill
50 ans nieline représentant du syndicat
SNESUP et puis également face à vous
Pauline forest bonsoir vous êtes
vice-présidente de l'UNFA 51 en niveline
personnel enseignant et étudiants de
votre établissement qui sont réunis en
intersyndicale mobilisé ce jeudi devant
le rectorat à Versailles gelle des
emplois plus globalement politiques
d'austérité c'est ce que vous craignez
en raison de ce déficit affiché de 4
millions d'euros quel est le bilan de
cette mobilisation de cette matinée
d'action chacun d'entre vous
euh bon déjà il y
avait un nombre relativement conséquent
je pense de d'étudiants et de personnel
qui sont venus devant le rectorat nous
avons été reçus nous avons donc pu
porter à la fois nos inquiétudes et nos
revendications et engagé directement les
représentants de
l'intersyndical et du syndicat étudiant
unf on VO les images avait environ une
centaines de de manifestants de
personnes mobilisé c'est ce que vous
attendiez oui oui oui c'est ce qu'on
attendait euh euh c'est ce qu'on
attendait tout à fait euh voilà après on
a on a on a on a eu un
échange intéressant disons avec le avec
le rectorat mais l'incertitude reste
reste entière et je crois pas qu'on ait
eu matière à être rassuré sur ce qui
nous attend 2014 échange qui a duré à
peu près 1hure et3 justement au rectorat
ce matin on va on va y revenir dans un
instant nous verrons le le reportage que
nous avons consacré à cette mobilisation
auparavant j'aimerais vous entendre sur
le le bilan que vous pouvez tirer de de
cette première mobilisation
intersyndicale bah c'est un bilan très
satisfaisant parce que comme l'a
souligné mon collègue les les étudiants
en tout cas été présents au côté des
personnels pour faire entendre leur voix
le but c'était vraiment de de souligner
que les étudiants sont inquiets pour
l'avenir de leur formation dans le
contexte difficile qu'on traverse donc
c'est important que le le bah simplement
les décisions qui seront prises à
l'avenir ne se fassent pas sans les
étudiants puisque voilà nous sommes les
usagers de cette université et nous
sommes intéressés pour laavenè de nos
formations ça nous concerne tous une
manifestation locale qui en appelle une
autre au niveau national journée de
mobilisation nationale pour s'opposer au
budget d'austérité des établissements ce
sera demain on va aussi en parler avec
nos invités mais déjà les images donc de
cette opération ce matin à
versaill personnel ne pas
l'austérité une centaine de personnes
rassemblées ce jeudi devant le rectorat
ils sont étudiants enseignants ou
personnel de l'université de versailles-
Saint-Quentin Unis sous une bannière
intersyndicale leur inquiétude
l'université affiche un déficit de 4
millions d'euros et cela pourrait avoir
des répercussions sur leurs conditions
de travail depuis le début de l'année il
y a des restrictions budgétaires qui
sont faites sur l'ensemble des
composants de l'UVSQ concrètement c'est
20 % de restriction par composante et
donc ça se traduit par par exemple la
DVE qui a plus les moyens de faire des
photocopies pour les étudiants ça se
traduit par des heures de TD qui sont
supprimé des cm qui des des heures de TD
qui sont transféré en cours magistraux
dans des amphis bondés et c'est 50 %
d'échec aujourd'hui en première année de
licence à l'UVSQ parce que justement
l'UVSQ et l'État ne mettent pas les
moyens suffisants pour la réussite de
tous des formations qui sont menacées
notamment la filière
STAPS pour laquelle on supprime un
parcours de Licence alors même qu'il y a
des étudiants tout ce qui fait le
fonctionnement de l'université
c'estàdire les personnels et les
formations sont sacrifiés pour résoudre
les problèmes de déficit qui sont liés
donc à des la signature de deux
partenariats publics très coûteux mais
aussi et surtout à un absence de finance
les syndicats réclament par exemple que
pour chaque diplôme soit affecté un
nombre de postes précis et inscrit dans
une loi une délégation a été reçue
pendant 1 he et dem par les services du
rectorat ils n'ont pas obtenu de réponse
à leurs inquiétudes car la notification
budgétaire allouée à l'université pour
2014 n'est pas encore connue si déjà le
budget n'est pas de 4 millions plus
élevé par rapport à l'anné dernière
c'est c'est de toute façon impossible
mais après il faut discuter sur sont les
besoins réels de l'université pour
qu'elle continue à
fonctionner sur des bases qui sont des
bases normales le rectorat
reconnu a indiqué ne pas vouloir
abandonner l'université que l'UVSQ était
une
université de réussite nous attendons
maintenant comme le disait l'ancienne
ministre il n'y a pas d'amour sans
preuve d'amour nous attendons les
preuves d'amour de la part du ministère
qui permettront de poursuivre cette
politique ambitieuse notamment autour de
la réussite des étudiants la prochaine
étape c'est la tenue mardi 17 décembre
du d'administration de l'université qui
va statuer sur le budget 2014
l'intersyndical fera de nouveau entendre
sa
voix on vient de voir le résumé de cette
matinée d'action on a entendu notamment
au tout début du sujet le personnel ne
pra pas l'austérité c'est votre crainte
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça se traduit
déjà au quotidien oui il faut bien
comprendre que à l'vsq comme dans
beaucoup d'autres établissements
l'austérité elle est déjà à l'œuvre ça a
été dit dans le reportage notamment par
par l'étudiant du nef nous avons gelé
des postes nous avons effectivement
fermé des TD nous avons fermé des
tutoras nous avons donc euh pris des des
des des mesures de restrictions
budgétaires qui ont un impact direct sur
les conditions d'études les conditions
de travail des personnels ça c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est certain ce que nous a
dit le le rectorat au fond euh c'est
c'est c'est c'est qu'on ne sait pas hein
on ne sait pas sur les 4 millions qui
sont devenus plutôt 5 millions
d'ailleurs hein euh nous avons 800000 €
euh qui a été effectivement affecté à
l'université pour payer ces factures au
sens strict et nous avons donc encore
ces 4 millions qui sont des engagements
que nous avons pris que N nous devons
évidemment honoré et qui sont reportés
sur 2014 donc la question reste entière
sachant que et là-dessus la contrôleuse
budgétaire du rectorat a été très clair
hein la personne qui nous a reçu le le
budget 2014 ne pourra en aucun cas être
à l'équilibre ce qui est une obligation
pour les établissement d'enseignement
supérieur donc la balle est clairement
dans le camp du ministère que fait-on
pour le v et pour la quinzaine ou
peut-être même vingtaine
d'établissements qui seront en déficite
à la fin à la fin deannée effectivement
Versailles SaintQuentin n'est pas le
seul établissement du supérieur dans
cette dans cette situation en tant
qu'étudiante ces étudiants est-ce que
sur le terrain ils ont des conditions
aujourd'hui qui sont plus difficiles
pour pour étudier au quotidien pour
travailler bah bien entendu quand la
direction enfin quand la direction
choisi de répercuter les restrictions
budgétaires auxquelles on fait face sur
les conditions d'étude des étudiants
c'est évid que ça impacte sur leur
réussite surtout qu'à l'heure actuelle
il y a quand même enfin le taux d'échec
en licence c'est un étudiant sur deux
qui n'arrive pas à valider sa première
année et ben quand on supprime des cours
quand on choisit de en effet supprimer
les tutorat et ben ça c'est des
étudiants qui réussissent moins et ça va
dans le sens inverse de la mission de
service public qui est censé remplir
l'université par ailleurs faut savoir
que les restriction elle pèse pas que
sur la réussite des étudiants mais elle
pèse aussi sur leur situation sociale
parce que quand on a juste justement la
direction de la vie étudiante qui ne
délivre plus de photocopies ou quand on
demande à l'UFR de santé de faire payer
aux étudiants leur polyopi de cours bah
concrètement c'est des dépenses
auxquelles les étudiants ne pour
certains ne peuvent pas faire face et en
tout cas c'est des dépenses qui sont qui
s'ajoutent à toutes celles auxquelles on
a à faire à faire face toute l'année
donc c'est clairement pas acceptable
j'imis revenir sur les les raisons de
cette situation 4 millions d'euros de
déficit pour cette année comment ça
s'explique euh de de deux deux
explications principales hein la
première je pense c'est c'est bien sûr
le le le sousfinancement chronique des
universités puisque encore une fois l'
VSQ n'est pas le seul établissement dans
ce dans cette situation qu'on explique
par le passage aux responsabilités et
compétences élargies ça veut dire que
les les universités ont au jour
d'aujourd'hui la responsabilité la
compétence et l'obligation de gérer la
pénurie que nous que nous propose le
ministère donc ça c'est le premier
élément l'élément second pour l'vsq
c'est bien sûr notamment la signature de
ces fameux PPP partenariat public privé
qui commence à être un peu connu par
l'actualité et notammentisation
notamment de la Faculté de Médecine
voilà la faculté de médecine et surtout
un deuxème PPP coféli pour l'entretien
des bâtiments sur ce point précis nos
revendications sont quand même très
claires et très et très précise et
immédiate c'est la sortie de
CPPP pour coféli a priori une
renégociation est en cours nous avons eu
l'assurance et j'espère que ça sera
suivi des faits que le le rectoral
ministère nous soutiendra et nous
portera son son aide y compris technique
et d'expertise pour sortir l'UVSQ de de
ce parten public privé qui nous coûte
énormément d'argent pour un résultat
d'ailleurs qui est qui n'est pas du tout
satisfaisant je crois que tout le monde
s'en rend compte voilà donc ça erreur de
gestion répétée déclaration budgétaire
non sincère ce sont des accusations
plutôt graves de la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur en vert à
l'encontre de l'Université de versaill
saqutins en nibline jeunev forasso donc
je répète erreur de gestion répétée
déclaration budgétaire non sincère vous
approuvez ces déclarations vous pensez
que c'est le cas ah bah oui ben nous
nous sommes pas contrôleur budgétaire
nous n'étions pas présents comme
contrôleur budgétaire comme le rectorat
dans le conseil d'administration depuis
des années donc qui était présent au
moment où ces choses là sont faites euh
moi je qu que les choses sont exposées
aujourd'hui vous imaginez que c'est
envisageable ce sont des accusations
graves he qui sont oui alors ce sont les
accusations soyons clair qui porte sur
la période de qui qui qui qui suit le
passage aux responsabilités compétences
élargies c'est-à-dire c'est la période
en gros 2010 2012 c'est donc l'ancienne
présidence qui est qui est visée dans
dans cette dans cette dans ces dans ces
accusations l'ancienne présidente oui
moi nous l'ONS dénoncé de toute façon
pendant son mandat ces ces ces heures de
gestion et ces choix politiques qu'on
qu'on estimait extrêmement dangereux
pour l'établissement malheureusement
nous avons eu raison on voit aujourd'hui
la question quand même que je souhaite
poser la ministre a a des à des mots
très durs envers ancienne présidente
mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire cette
ancienne présidente est toujours sa
représentante puisqu'elle est rectrice
de l'académie de dijonrice nous nous
n'avons pas vocation à à quoi que ce
soit nous ne sommes pas nous n'avons pas
les dossiers Pr ici c'est le ministère
et le rectorat qui les a qui tire toutes
les conséquences sur ce qui s'est passé
précisément dans cette périodeel nous ce
qui nous importe c'est l'avenir
justement l'avenir il va falloir de
toute façon faire des économies quoi
qu'il en soit est-ce que on va donner la
parole aussi pour l'Unef est-ce que les
étudiants est-ce que vous imaginez du
côté de l'UNEF devoir faire des que
l'université soit obligée de faire des
économies non justement à mon sens le
enfin de toute façon la direction de
l'université a clairement déclaré que en
effet c'était de nouvelles restrictions
qui nous attendait h euh or c'est
euh à mon sens c'est c'est justement ces
restrictions qu'il faut remettre en
cause parce que de toute façon on ne
peut pas d'un côté dénoncer le
sous-financement de l'État et de l'autre
ben finalement justement faire avec ce
qu'on nous donne et ben finalement
imposer de nouvelles restrictions
budgétaires qui vont se répercuter sur
les conditions d'études des étudiants
sur les conditions de travail euh qui
peuvent se traduire par de nouvelles
suppressions de cours de peut-être déjà
des salaires je ne sais pas mais euh
toujours est-il que il faut au contraire
que l'université prenne ses
responsabilités euh ben disent que oui
en effet ça va mal et du coup ben exiger
un un financement plus important de la
part de l'État une dotation plus
importante euh et surtout aller vers
justement la sanctuirisation des
formations la sanctuirisation surtout
des formations de premier cycle puisque
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera maintenir
ben justement la mission de service
public qui revient à l'université donc
s'assurer que les cours soit maintenu
que nos conditions de travail puissent
redevenir celles qu'elles étaient euh
qu'on puisse récupérer nos cours
enseigner dans enfin qu'on est des
enseignements délivrés dans de bonnes
conditions et ça ben ça ça ne peut pas
passer par de nouvelles restrictions
budgétaires donc il va falloir que
l'état donne plus d'argent c'est ce que
vous nous dites en substance depuis
depuis tout à l'heure finalement ça veut
dire qu'il faut revenir totalement sur
cette loi d'autonomie des universités
non seulement il faut revenir sur cette
lo l'autonomie les RC je vois pas qui
peut aujourd'hui les défendre encore une
fois nous avvez est vendu comme un un
dispositif qui permettrait aux
établissements de développer leur
activité résultat il y a un universit
notamment avec les autres universités
européennes et international on voit
bien qu'en période difficile c'est les
universités qui doivent faire les
économies sur le sur leur ce qui est le
cœur de leur mission donc bien sûr il
faut il faut mettre en cause les RCE
mais il y a aussi des choix budgétaires
évidents là-dessus je veux bien qu'on
qu'on qu'on qu'on tire à boulet rouge la
ministre tire à boulet rouge sur sur
l'ciène présidente après tout c'est
encore une fois à elle de de régler ces
ces questions là mais j'ai quand même on
a quand même envie aussi de mettre de
être un peu la ministre devant ses
responsabilités le crédit impôt
recherche c'est 6 milliards en 2014 le
crédit impôt recherche c'est 6 milliards
ça coûte 6 milliards au objet de l'État
la Cour des comptes reconnaît que c'est
une relative inefficacitéin vous
prendrez 15 % de ce montant vous le
donnez au aux université il n'y a plus
de problème de doation budgétaire donc
il ne s'agit pas de dire que augment
même pas augmenter le budget de l'État
il y a quand même des choix qui sont
faits dans le budget contraint de l'État
qui est de 2014 qui qui qui plonge des
facto les univers dans les situations
difficilees là c'est c'est très très pré
7 universités déficitair en 2012 il
devrait y en avoir 19 pour 2013 au moins
5 universités devrait afficher de années
successives de déficit également donc ça
ne concerne pas que l'université de
Versailles saint-quanttin en Yveline
c'est pour cela qu'il aura une
manifestation avec les différents
établissement universitaire ce sera
demain à partir de 14h30 à Paris à
partir de juciieux vous y serez présent
manif c'était cet après-midi pardon nous
avons appelé effectivement il y avait
une délégation qui était présente à
cette manifestation oui oui tout à fait
et il y aura également le 17 décembre et
là la bonne date le conseil
d'administration pour l'université de
Versailles 550 anine pour statuer sur le
budget 2014 nous aurons donc l'occasion
d'en reparler de cette situation
financière merci à tous les deux on
termine avec de la politique nouveau
rendez-vous pour les électeurs avec
l'équipe municipale de manilo l'occasion
pour le maire de faire un état des lieux
avec les habitants de sa commune sur
place Olivier
Maniscalco une nouvelle réunion publique
se tenait mercredi soir au Centre bless
Pascal de manilamo entre le maire
socialiste Bertrand Ouillon et les
habitants de la commune occasion de
faire un bilan du mandat écoulé avant
les municipales de mars 2014 l'occasion
également de réfléchir aux axes du
prochain programme d'abord on partage
notre bilan qui nous permet de faire un
état des lieux avec les habitants qui
leur permet aussi de pouvoir nous
apporter leur contribution et nous
présenterons notre programme notre
projet bien entendu avant les élections
dans le premier trimestre 2014 nos axes
sont en premier la famille et les
services aux habitants dans les services
aux habitants ça concerne du parcours de
la vie et dans le parcours de la vie il
y a le parcours résidentiel mais aussi
des services liés à l'ensemble de la
famille petite enfance enfance jeunesse
senior il faut que toutes les personnes
tous les habitants de notre commune
puisse bien vivre tous ensemble à Man
une trentaine de personnes étaient
présentes pour participer au débat en
mars prochain Bertran Ouillon sera
notamment confronté dans les urnes à
Aurore berger la candidate UMP une
candidate quecqu col l'ancien maire de
la commune n'épargne pas c'est une femme
d'appareil tout
simplement et que ça mere j'auris
préféré que l'UMP choisisse quelqu'un
donc sur qui a la connaissance de la
commune qui ne vient pas ici uniquement
pour faire une carrière
politicienne cette réunion publique
clôturait les rencontres citoyennes
organisé par l'équipe municipale le
prochain rendez-vous avec les Manis du
maire candidat Bertron Ouillon se
tiendra en
janvier le journal qui revient donc
demain à 18h le point sur l'information
du jour et puis comme chaque vendredi
retour également sur l'essentiel de la
semaine écoulée ce jeudi soir sur TVfil
78 vous avez rendez-vous avec Claire
Cambier pour filcho le magazine
économique de la rédaction très bonne
soirée